[Music]
thank you so much and welcome everyone
to this debate on form and ritual power
and prejudice thank you so much for
joining us so from greetings and
introductions to loves and relationships
church services and dances formality and
ritual were once a central part of our
lives but form and ritual have been in
retreats for more than a century now
many see it as a formality as outdated
an unnecessary sign of deference and
welcome a less constrained more open
culture
should we see formality in ritual as a
power play that embeds hierarchy and
prejudice and seek to eradicate it or
might the abandonment of ritual be a
contemporary mistake
as social rules
are social rules as some in the metoo
movement have argued a defense for the
vulnerable and can ritual this out of
the mundane and every day to higher and
better goals to discuss these very
topical issues i'm joined by a wonderful
panel of speakers historian of ideas and
lecturer on the history of political
thought at king's college london hannah
dawson is one of the leading experts on
how thought itself has changed over the
centuries
also
on the panel is distinguished professor
of religion and society at lancaster
university linda woodhead who has an mbe
for her services to higher education and
is one of the leading experts in the
world on christianity
noel carroll is a renowned philosopher
of arts whose most celebrated work
includes the philosophy of horror and
humor a very short introduction his
expertise covers the philosophy of
cinema theatre fine art dance and just
about any artistic medium that you can
think of so welcome to our panel and
thank you to all of you who are joining
us here today the way this is gonna go
is each of our speakers will now have
three minutes to lay out their position
in their pitch and i'm gonna ask
the first speaker to come up today if
that's possible hannah dawson could you
lay out for us in three minutes whether
we should seek to eradicate formality
and ritual
thank you miriam and hello everybody
um
i think that we need to be very wary
of
formality and ritual because i think
that they can be means of oppressing
people and i think that they can oppress
people in two ways that i'm going to lay
out now
so the first one is that i think that
formality and ritual can actually bring
into being and reinforce
hierarchies illegitimate hierarchies
between individuals so if you think of
something very basic um like bowing and
curtsying these things seem very small
and insignificant but i think that
there's a way in which they
um
that by bowing and by curtsying we start
to embody relations of power and if we
think about the um the sociologist
pierre bourdieu he had this idea of
habitus which was the idea that um small
acts of moving our bodies of practice in
the world they embody power relations so
that when we bow we come to feel
ourselves inferior when we are bowed at
we come to feel ourselves superior um so
it creates rituals create realities
they create social realities and even
rituals that seem very insignificant and
harmless even polite and helpful like
for example opening a door for a woman
saying ladies first that that reinforces
particular stereotypes of weakness and
of difference and of dependency between
the sexes
and the second way in which i think that
we have to be wary of formality and
ritual because they can oppress people
is that
in invoking formality and being polite
and being civil and obeying the rules
telling people to watch their tone or
calm down be civil we can often be
suppressing we can be crushing we can be
silencing legitimate anger and
resistance so for example if we think
about the recent black lives matter
movement
um
this uh elicited a kind of backlash of
people saying be civil be kind as those
somehow calling out racism were worse
than the racism that was being called
out civility it seems to me formality is
often used as a mask for a justification
for oppression and we see that very
clearly if we think historically about
the whole idea of the civilizing mission
we're actually which was all about
legitimizing empire where actually what
is coded as civil is in fact
the very thing that causes the most kind
of barbarism
um
and this leads on to my kind of final
thought which is that often one needs to
be uncivil one needs to break the rules
in order to stand up against um
injustice and i'd like to end with a
quote from frederick douglass the great
abolitionist theorist who um who says
power concedes nothing without a demand
power oppression injustice rely on quiet
submission to the rules the only way in
which we can actually
progress in which we can bring justice
about in the society is by standing up
to it in an uncivil way
thank you
thank you so much for that lots of uh
food for thoughts kick us off there and
next up i'd like to put the same
question to linda woodhead
should we seek to eradicate formality
and ritual thanks very much i was just
reading a book which i really recommend
called paper cuts by stephen bernard and
it's um it's rather a harrowing story
about his sexual abuse and rape
by a catholic priest when he was a young
boy
stephen bernard is now
an academic at oxford university and he
talks about how difficult it has been to
hold his life together as a victim of
abuse and uh about the medication he's
on about the therapy he has to have
about the sheer difficulty of keeping
his identity together having had it
ripped apart so repeatedly
and one thing that struck me in this is
that he says that every night when he
goes to bed
he writes a note about what he did that
day at work and what he has to do in the
morning
so that when he wakes up the first thing
he does is pick up that piece of paper
and look at who he is
it's a ritual
it's essential to holding him together
and i'm gonna argue that we need to keep
ritual and formality
for two reasons it's focusing
and it's fortifying
let me just say what i mean by ritual
ritual is
repetition
it's bodily it has to include the bodily
in quite a profound way good rituals do
things that to do with things like
eating or being covered in water or sex
or very bodily things
so
repetition body but also
some intention you're intentionally
doing these things
and attention you're paying attention
when you're doing those things so ritual
in that sense i think we just all have
them and we'd fall apart without them i
start every day with a cup of tea in bed
brought by my husband who's not very
he's not very civil uh and he's not a
particularly good ritual practitioner i
have to make him do this but it's a very
essential ritual for me i just could not
start the day without it and i do pay
attention and i do try and gather myself
together
and um
yeah i it's it's very very important
um
so small things they can give a focus
i've talked about them as a focus
there's a great ritual theorist called
jonathan z phillips who talks about
ritual as a focusing lens and he gives
the example of tribes he worked with
he's an anthropologist uh who before a
hunt always do a ritual in which they're
playing through what they're going to do
in the hunt they're getting themselves
into that mind they're focusing on the
perfect hunt so they can then put that
into action i think sports people do
something similar these days
so focusing and fortifying and we need
fortification it's about support we
support ourselves god knows we need
support these days uh and we can have
our own personal rituals to support
ourselves it's very nice sometimes when
you have collective rituals that give
you solidarity and support particularly
if you're an oppressed group
trying to have a stand uh hannah made
some excellent points i don't disagree
ritual can be abused but think how
important it was in the usa for example
in slaves being able to stand together
and keep going and have a common voice
thank you so much linda no should we
seek to eradicate formality and ritual
well let me let me start by just saying
i'm not really comfortable with the
terms of the discussion uh for two
reasons
first because it runs together two
notions uh that of ritual and that of
formality
they may overlap
but there are important differences
between them that will certainly
complicate actually have already
complicated our discussion
rituals are in with important respects
practices uh that we set aside uh we put
them off from the flow of everyday life
they're events that are made special uh
they're platforms uh for all sorts of
things
formalities on the other hand are
indispensable to the flow of life
or at least some of them
hewing for example
we may sometimes call
some everyday formalities rituals
but that i i think is to speak merely
figuratively
perhaps as a way to disparage them as
outmoded
my second reason for discomfort is its
generality
it sounds as if we're being asked to
rule on all formalities and all rituals
that seems to me quixotic
formalities and rituals evolve socially
to serve purposes
which they do badly or well or
indifferently
the purposes in turn
that they serve are needful useful
optimal or benign
and will be judged in terms of among
other things their necessity their
efficiency
their fitness in the context they occur
uh
and their justice and fairness of course
as hannah dawson was was
emphasizing
how we stand on an example of formality
or a specific ritual
will depend upon our consideration of
the purposes they serve
first and foremost
as well as the degree to which they do
or don't serve them
so my my view uh in my view a summary
verdict on all formality along with oral
ritual would be very ill advised
i don't know
who planned the order of this but
somehow mystically they put me in the
position of the some do some don't
position
maybe just because somebody said oh he's
a philosopher they thought that that's
where he would wind up
but of course i agree um with the points
that both the previous speakers have
have made
hannah gave especially good examples of
uh misuse of of formalities and rituals
and uh linda uh uh actually anticipated
a number of the things i was going to
say about uh the uh power of ritual to
uh foster attention uh focusing and and
fortification um uh as uh uh uh uh will
become evident uh i think of rituals
especially in terms of their capacity to
cause um emotional unity uh
as as a means of of attention and uh
focus and fortification thanks
thank you so much to our speakers for
laying out their position there now
let's dive straight into it
our traditions have been long-standing
and we do things a certain way be they
due to customs morality or religion
we're speaking here from uh the united
kingdom where um to be knighted is to be
united by the royal family in a very uh
ritualistic process which some might
argue uh reinforces social class by um
rendering certain groups within society
able to uh bestow certain honors over
others and elevate them as it were
socially and economically but rituals
mark key moments in our lives be they
marriage or funeral
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas